quem sabe o que eu não assisto Big
Brother só que o Big Brother coisa que
chega até você você não quiser assistir
para saber que todo mundo fala só fala
disso pocaralho sobre o que aconteceu
ontem no programa O Caio o pai da menina
cada um beijo na boca do cara tá
acreditando em mim aula mesmo usar o que
colocar na Advance ou as coisas acontece
caso não paga não sei o que o tipo a
televisão inventa coisas para passar na
pessoas cara coisa feia meu irmão que
que o povo assiste essas coisas carai é
esse foi o que acontece aí eu entrei
isso aí não sei cara estou indignado
também de noite eu vou assistir para
saber o que é